foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
and go to Twitter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what's going on guys
um trying to
get King in here
and once King gets in here we will start
the show
we will start the show
but like I said man take that take that
URL at the top yeah we
hoping for a decent turnout run with
this with this show
like a decent one guys
all right now it should work
hold up
so let's just
I don't think it's gonna I don't think
that's working
might just have to do it the other way
be right back guys
thank you
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
you guys should be able to hear me you
guys should be able to hear King
everything's good
not really but it's it's fine
it's fine let me adjust this a little
bit
oh
you saw the the the stuff inside the
chat right I mean well inside our
Dropbox
well what's in the Dropbox the popcorn
and stuff yeah yeah it's there okay I
thought we put that like after like we'd
determine if it gets like
yeah you should be able to hear me both
so that this is the new overlay
um
King sought this out
uh I I I like it a little bit more now
just I just part we don't like the small
I feel
I feel claustrophobic
and digitally right now I don't know why
I feel a little claustrophobic but I'll
get used to it I get used to it so this
is the new show r r is with me uh me and
King this is going to be the majority of
us is going to be me and King now I'm
not going to say that we won't
occasionally have other people or you
know the other Lords in here from time
to time depending on what kind of big
stuff goes on but for the most part this
is what you guys are gonna see uh so
what what
this one's gonna be about Black Panther
we'll call it forever uh I've seen it
and so is king So we're gonna this is
how the layout of the show gonna be 30
minutes we're gonna talk about spoiler
free scenarios where you know you could
safely listen to it but then the other
30 minutes of the show it's going to be
spoiler territory uh this episode I
won't be able to do it but I'm
eventually going to have something on
the screen that's like indicating this
is a spoiler part of the show so King
where you want to start with uh Black
Panther man where you want to start all
right first we gotta fix your camera
because your head is cut off
all right so it's like showing though
whatever it's zooming in it's showing
you the bottom half of your camera right
and uh on my side it looks fine are you
sure like reframe you know I'm looking
at it at that on the channel
so okay where you want to start yeah
yeah I I adjusted it like live
oh okay start with uh black all right
yeah it looks so so where you want to
start with black panther man because I I
seen it last night when did you see it
we'll start with that I saw it uh the
day after it came out
um
and
you know I went in with trepidations uh
to go see the film because I didn't know
how they were going to handle uh
Chadwick Boseman uh how they was going
to handle
um
name or how they was going to handle
shuri how they was going to handle
because I knew ahead of time
the the the the main plot points and the
characters that were involved so I
didn't know how they were going to
handle it and coming from Black Panther
where it was a large film
to fill those shoes
was going to be immense it was it was
going to be like a herculin task within
itself and
you know for the first couple of minutes
I was I was like man they're missing the
mark to be honest with you with how it
started because you know it's it's it's
in a crisis moment type of thing and
I'm just like oh my God what what are
they doing where are they going with
this and and you know for the most part
they they kind of cleared it up very
quickly very
urgently in the beginning to let you
know they were in a crisis moment as far
as Marvel goes when Chadwick uh passed
away they didn't know how to handle it
and the film conveys that in in the
beginning in in like the opening act of
it and
um it's it's it was a very sobering take
on how to handle
the untimely passing of a character that
is the main character for your film and
I think
um they did a fantastic I think Kugler
excuse me in the team did a fantastic
job in in that opening act
how did you feel with the opening I I
feel you on the opening act I think um
you know one of the biggest critiques I
can give with the opening act is I
understand you know the criteria that
was given into
the the reason why it happened but I
felt like the reason behind
what happened to him was a little bit
too unknown and part of he understands
why they did it but the other party's
like if you're going to write off a
character you might as well give context
to how they died if that makes sense
right they didn't really do that it was
just like yeah they left it too big yeah
and I felt like
there might have been reasons and
reasonings for but I don't understand a
reasoning to not understanding why he
passed away like clearly it was I think
it was some disease that that finally
got to him but you know in the older
episodes there was no in the older
movies there was no reasoning to if he
was sick so it wouldn't make sense
generally okay so like in the books in
um I think it's called Uh
doom doom something like uh like Doom
Siege or whatever
uh t'challa gets Poisoned With vibranium
poisoning vibranium is actually
poisoning
um the wakandans and
um I forgot what it's it was it was Doom
something because that the overarching
plot line of it was uh Doctor Doom
invading wakanda to try to you know take
away all the resources of as far as
vibranium goes uh they could have
probably touched on that but I don't
think they wanted to talk about
vibranium poisoning and then I think
they wanted to
try to respect Chadwick Boseman
um in some regard and I don't think they
wanted to touch on anything as far as
grounded disease level like in the real
world in their world which absolutely
makes no sense but again it's it's
straddling the fence of being respectful
to the the core audience and being
respectful to Chadwick if if you kind of
get my drift yeah and then plus I do
feel like you have the
obviously we'll get into the the ending
thing I think that you know they they
did everything with the intentions of
what the ending cut scene is and we'll
go over that a little bit more
um obviously we have we have the main
Pro antagonists of this uh a name or I
believe that's what his name is yeah how
do you feel like they they they did him
in this movie without really going into
spoiler with that okay so like going
into it and I'm seeing the trailers and
stuff right I'm a huge and Amor fan I
got two statues I got a sideshow OG uh
name on Statue I got
um a couple of Bowens that I have my eye
on as soon as the price drops down on
those statues then I'll probably pick
them up one day uh I think 300 for uh um
a one-fifth or one sixth scale statue is
too much but you know price to drop down
they're pretty old and I have the XM
Studios
um Namor on octopus I'm a huge Neymar
fan I've been a Neymar fan sister child
uh you know Emperors Rex the the the the
the prince and the king of Atlantis uh
these these things were ingrained in me
from very young he's the first uh comic
book character that Marvel produced
under another name but um
again you know he uh he's the first
mutant and it's it's something to behold
when you know that that character is
coming to screen so I had different
expectations different actors that I
wanted to uh to to play him and I
thought his body type didn't fit what my
Envision of him was you got like that
swimmer uh yeah going on then when I
then when he got to the screen
and I saw his acting powers
and I saw the direction that they were
going in
and I felt I'm comfortable I'm
absolutely completely comfortable in
everything that they're doing with him
you know
um
it was it was
it was something amazing to behold you
know how
they made you understand how powerful he
was in and out of water
[Music]
um how agile he was in and out of water
and how he got around very fast in
certain aspects and very quietly uh he's
he's a stealth assassin he's a brute at
times he's very intelligent and he's a
king and I thought
it was all put front and center
and his love for his people
showed out more it was something to be
seen it was I was taken aback because I
really thought they could have messed it
up they could have really went left with
it
yeah Namor actually
I felt like they did a good job showing
that this individual
can be an aggressive person in the drop
of a dime and as long as you stay on his
good side he won't go that way
um you know in it
it's very hard to show character in a
very dominant way but show weakness at
the same time and they did that very
well on here you know especially there's
certain things of of the the movie where
he's like look I'm strong but I know
I'm not like I can't be defeated and
he's got like a lot of fear tactics in
him like it's like look like we don't
want the outside to know of us and you
know I like how they're very very extra
with those those kind of thought process
because when you look at something like
what's wrong I'm looking for
you look at all the other mcu's
the way he acts in this movie would
explain why he's never been heard of and
so now yep
because he's very secretive on his
Nation
yep
because he understands the value of the
commodity that he does have and um and
then exploring his origin uh gave to you
by the movie you got a glimpse into why
his uh his distrust or his anger or
hatred towards uh humans
or you got to see humans because of uh
tolikens is really and they're not
lanterns they're tolucans
um are uh against you know the human
population as far as what they projected
to him you know when he got a chance to
see with his own eyes uh so he saw the
the worst side of uh Humanity at a very
young age and that uh formulated his
opinion of the surface dwellers so you
can see why he kept his people uh safe
and secure and in the darkest reaches of
the um Marianas Trench and uh the
Bermuda Triangle for uh lack of a better
word and it's kind of crazy like the
extranists they have to do to get to
that place like this isn't just a place
where you just dive in like you had to
take uh you know streams there like they
like I want you guys to realize like it
is not easy to get to his his kingdom
like it is very deep under the uh the
you know the sea and I and I like that
because
the reason I wanted them to be so extra
with where he's located is because I
wanted it to be very clear look it's not
it's not a wonder why no one found him
right like because I hate when when they
Implement something later on in in a
franchise such as like MCU and you're
like why have why hasn't he been around
this whole time it's because he is
chosen not to be around this whole time
exactly he's chosen to keep his people
hidden you know at all times I love how
uh the US government is is baffled that
is there another nation is there
somebody else honing in on the vibranium
do they have vibranium uh what what's
going on and they're totally in the dark
and he wants it that way yeah and what's
funny is
he knows he could take humans he knows
that for the most part like he could he
could body any
low like you know any of uh any of the
United Nations he knows that his people
can Massacre those people because you
know you see multiple times that their
their actual armor can withstand bullets
it doesn't really matter you know it
would take a lot to actually go through
them but he but when vibranium starts
getting put in the conversation he's
like okay this is this could actually do
something to us because this is the only
material that can actually hurt us
and and the the difference between
wakanda and vibranium and uh tolokin
vibranium is tolkan's vibranium
is pure right raw vibranium the
wakanda's vibranium is processed they
put it through a processing right so
they make it malleable to use in a lot
of different like tools uh you know
because when when the military went on a
strike they were looking for tools they
weren't looking for weapons they weren't
looking for they were just looking for
tools anything that has any vibranium
compound in it that they can use so the
wakandans use the technology
for technology sake and
the tolkiens they used it for you say
armor spoons forks you know uh materials
of that nature very very Earthly
materials very grounded materials
they're very wholesome uh people like
when you got a chance to see their their
their space their space was is it felt
so ink and so Mayan so so very very rich
in Mexican culture that it felt real
like that their their culture the I like
the way they cultivated their culture
their culture came across very well he
was very proud when he when when they
got a chance to you know talk about it
and see it all right so you know I think
we'll probably uh move over to the
spoiler territories now because oh
spoiler time there's only so much we
could talk about without spoiling I feel
like a lot of people's already watched
this is it's like one of those big
movies where people generally watch it
in the first week so I will give you
guys 10 seconds to vacate the premises
if you have not seen black panther uh
ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one okay I gave you guys plenty of
time all right so first off I want to
talk about is
black panther uh you know there was a
lot of speculation going on who was
going to pick up the man to a black
panther and I think everyone pretty much
knew who was going to do it I don't know
why there was a lot of speculation going
on it uh it it was a sister man Sherry
she ended up getting it you know what I
really enjoyed about this King
is how well
that they show that's like look not only
does is she the Black Panther now they
wouldn't have been nothing without her
in the first play because she's always
been the the person pushing their
technology and what I like about this is
even if
they had her brother still alive they
couldn't have defeated this person
without her without her her her mind on
top of the Black Panther whoa
here's where I give you a little bit of
pushback
um the McGuffin in the film is Riri
Williams ironheart
and she is a genius level
um yeah ironheart that's what the name
is ironheart yeah well she had a lot to
do with the two but I feel like she was
definitely helping but I feel like she
was focusing more on her suit than she
was helping with the you know she they
it was more of like bouncing back and
forth that led to what was Neymar's
weakness
all right she but she helped her uh uh
uh craft the ship yeah the [ __ ] yeah
they both worked on the ship together
but again you see what she's able to
create so like Tony Stark and just give
you an encapsulation of this what this
character is Tony Stark made his
materials from a cave right in Crunch
and he got the rudimentary uh Iron Man
put together and he did that she without
that level of crunch without that level
of um gun Tire head she put together her
own Iron Man suit and made an arc
reactor now of course if it's something
that you see that you can emulate it if
you see it you can figure it out you can
reverse engineer stuff if you can have a
thought yeah I understand that you saw
Tony first so Tony is a schematic but
this kid is such a genius that with
wakandan technology she was able to put
together an Iron Man suit of her own
and and that thing really kicked some
major tail because it had a uni beam it
had repulsory her own it was rail guns
um her own level of guns
um the jet repulsers which what she's
using was thrusters which wasn't you
know repulses different technology all
around and it performed in a high combat
situation
the kid is an absolute mind-boggling
genius at the age of three she was
making her own first you know um you
know experiments and stuff like that
that she talked about so I think she was
the McGuffin because remember without
her you don't get the vibranium finding
machine that that started all this mess
to begin with
yeah and what I liked about her too is
just how well they did her character
like she kind of took over the the the
comedy relief of the movie yeah she was
mainly the comedy relief I like how you
saw she was building that and I didn't
know much about the character so I
assume she's gonna stick around like
that's this is the last thing we're
gonna see her and what I like is her
suit
is clearly inspired by Tony by Iron Man
but it's yeah it's not the Iron Man suit
like it's clearly different and not just
the visualization of it the way it moves
too because you saw Tony do things but
she fights different than Tony yeah
because Tony would not have done nothing
that she did in this like Tony
completely for the most part Tony like
that that long distance mid distance
fight like he he would get close but he
wouldn't do it often yeah
um what what I loved about
um reread the character and she has a
series coming on uh Disney plus oh she
does yeah so she has got to be there
it's supposed to be next year oh you
know you know we're covering that yes of
course so we we have that and then um
you have uh what is it um Iron Wars uh
so that's going to cover you know Tony
Stark's lost Tech and I'm pretty sure
that she's going to be featured in that
film as well because I'm pretty sure
that uh this guy
um war machine is going to go after her
thinking that's Tony Tech and it's not
Tony's Tech you know once he gets a
chance to find out about it but you know
Sherry taking on the man tool of the
Black Panther and actually becoming
stepping into those shoes because it was
really technology versus culture and
tradition right and sure she kind of
went away from that yeah yeah she she
didn't believe in the old gods boss she
didn't believe that when you drink the
herb you get to see his dad
how you feel about killmonger showing up
I loved it yeah you know what's part of
me when killmonger was sitting there and
like he put the uh you know he was like
look what kind of black panther you
gonna be I would say I don't know why
but I was a killmonger crafter corrupter
because I've always like to me if I'd
had my way killmonger would have been
black panther I don't know why I always
liked the vibe he gave in Black because
he was a sympathetic to his cause
like he he brought you to his cars he
has a Swagger about him you know um
I I could say this right I I identified
with Sherry when when her brother passed
when when her brother passed she wanted
the world to burn
when when my late dog passed uh Lord
Benjamin Johnson
um
when he passed
I swear I wanted the world to burn
i i i i i i
a rage inside of my body that was so
infuriated I've never felt like that for
anybody like that that has passed away
you know love people or whatever but you
know um a dog's love is absolutely
unconditional so me missing out on that
that level I I saw her pain I saw her
frustration so her seeing killmonger
when she took the herb and they
synthesized the herb and we're going to
get to how they synthesize the herb but
when she took when she took the herb and
she thought she was going to see a
mother or she thought she was going to
see a brother and she's sore
her rage
she saw a killmonger there
and he asked her what type of black
panther we because you called me here
for a reason you know what I like the
sentence he said he's like are you going
are pretty much like you'll be a goody
two shoot like your brother or you're
gonna get [ __ ] done like me like I love
what he said that because it showed that
she's gonna be a different black panther
she's not going to be like her brother
but she's not gonna she's gonna be in
the middle
she's not gonna be like killmonger or
her brother she's going to be a middle
Black Panther
well Black Panther's real Noble
um she's a real see in in the cat family
the females are the hunters she's a very
vicious black panther she doesn't have
the fighting skills uh of black parents
that she has fighting skills she's been
trained as a kid all the way up through
her teens
to where she's at now in the comic book
she takes over as black panther as black
panther becomes
um the the panther god of the dead right
he ushers you know people to the dead um
I remember at IOP you said there was a
different there was another black
panther too like further on in the comic
books yes it was like you said like red
or white panther or something like that
yeah yeah there was that was something
that was some DC stuff
about that because but yeah what I find
it interesting is like they introduced a
bunch of different like elements in here
clearly we're seeing the uh another
group being formed by uh what's his
name's wife uh because uh because I was
told that she yeah she controls that
group and I didn't know this but uh yeah
the Thunderbolts I I didn't know this
but that
and the what's that what's the Captain
America and that TV show which one are
you talking about um yeah well it's not
that I didn't know that the Captain
America they replaced Captain America
with at first they they're changing him
to something else like yeah he's gonna
be in that I didn't know that see I
don't know nothing about comic books so
and that's the best part that's why I
wanted to do the show with you right
that's the best part you come from it
with open eyes
fresh eyes right so when I ask you I'm
asking you how you see it because I'm
coming in jaded man I'm like I'm coming
in so spoiled and so uh uh dirty from
comic books right so I know us agent I
know he was going to go bad I know that
stuff was going to happen I didn't know
that I know they was gonna actually put
the suit on you say you didn't know that
I didn't know like I knew he wouldn't be
captured America because he wasn't given
traits like you know at the end uh where
Sherry's about to to to kill him and and
my girl's like oh God and I was like no
Disney's Never Gonna Let black panther
kill someone like that exactly so I knew
that they weren't gonna let her go that
far they're gonna let her go over a
little bit but she was gonna eventually
get brought back to to the realization
of the Black Panther character but when
it came to him I knew they weren't going
to let him do that but I didn't know how
long they were going to let him lingle
around like that you know what I'm
saying let me say this
in the books
Neymar wouldn't yielded
yeah he's that arrogant
he's dead pompous
his dad Royal he's that Regal
he he is that guy
do you let me ask you a question because
uh Nemo clearly uh wants that's why I
said earlier when we weren't doing the
spoiler thing he clearly knows that his
days are numbered unless he allies up
unless he he gets help because he knows
like look right now we have the
advantage if we attacked you know the uh
if we attack the humans we would have a
huge Advantage but that's why he flipped
out when they got the vibranium because
when they when when America when London
because we saw that thing with London in
the beginning when they get their hands
on vibranium
they're going to take that to the dark
air they're you know and he knows that
like look we we wear a lot of we're
talking about when France and those
people over it's like we we have a lot
of vibranium armor but the only thing
that can really affect that is vibranium
and he he's flipping out on that and do
you how do you think they're going to
initialize his army and him back in the
movies like do you think it's gonna be a
while I kind of think it'll be one of
those things where it's going to be so
far off you're not going to remember him
and he's just gonna show up and help
someone in in a future movie or
something no um Okay so
Dr Doom and Neymar is really good
friends oh God
okay never mind you think he's gonna
come back as a bad guy well he is a bad
guy he's I didn't know that I thought I
thought he was an anti-villain like he
he's on either side whatever he's like
Black Adam Oh Black Adam okay I thought
he was like Vegeta like he yeah he he'll
he'll swing both ways if it benefits him
like he don't care so the thing with
that is he's looking for a nation to
pair up with him against humanity right
Dr Doom has latvaria
what is that so Liberia is is his his
continent it's like Russia
right so it's very huge it's it's it's
it's a nice sized chunk we've seen
latvaria inside uh Moon night they were
in that town remember in that town where
all the people was congregating around
that night okay you didn't watch my man
okay so it's in there see so you have
you have Hawkins too doom doom is coming
Doom is going to be the Doom is going to
be probably the true big bat but again I
think it's gonna be the dude from
King Wars in in the Multiverse and all
that other stuff we're gonna see that in
that man you think Kang is going to be
the main bad guy for the the Multiverse
Saga and then they'll bring someone else
after that or you think it's gonna be
one of those things where they dangle
paying in front of you and then you find
out he's working for someone like Doom
in the end and like the last Avengers
would be against him king is too big for
that you know he will be like the Thanos
of this franchise yeah he is he is but
see the thing with it is when we saw the
Loki uh uh story
um series
Cain explains to you upon them killing
him he's going to come back in other
iterations and his iterations are going
to be splintered through time so we
don't know if he talks to name more and
try to partner us up because when Neymar
yields to shuri in the in a great final
battle at the end it was a strategic
yield
because when he talks to neymarita his
his sister I mean was his his cousin
namora when he when he talks to her and
I also saw a tumor which is a huge
character inside that they had a lot of
huge characters that were being shown a
very prominent character it was funny I
didn't know any of them but I I was I
was fanboying out and he and she asks
him at Neymar at the end you know when
you know he's sitting there and he's
painting the wall you have the panther
God and you have uh the jaguar and
she said why why with these people
because when they Comfort them
and they will come for them
they're going to reach out back to us
they're going to have to because they
are the only strongest nation that can
actually stand up and you know they're
going to come for them in Black Panther
three and that that hopefully he doesn't
pair with doom before then but
and seeing how the art goes and then
seeing the queen die Namor having the
hand that put down the queen
I thought that was crossing the
boundaries I I thought it was no return
from that I I was like wow I didn't
think Angela Bassett was going to get
you know unalived at some point yeah
that caught me off guard because I felt
like because they killed uh obviously uh
you know the Black Panther at the
beginning they wouldn't touch another
person in this movie
I felt like but yeah they did man you
know what's funny is they show her
uh no Dan when the spoiler alerts up
that means we spoil in all types of
stuff
yeah
it's spoiler alert time bro I'm
eventually gonna have like a really nice
neon one looked on that so you know I'm
still gonna have in like in the middle
in the beginning you're gonna be sitting
in the trailer of the whatever we're
talking about I was going to do that but
I was really concerned on I know when
you do reactions those get hit with
strikes all the time so for real yeah so
when it comes to stuff like that I might
look into what exactly we can get away
with in this because games the gaming
industry don't care they're like show
anything for the most I think if it's
public domain trailers no trailers get
him reactions all the time now I don't
know maybe maybe it would be different
after the movie came out maybe they
won't be pushing so hard but I do know
that they they will get you up out of
there over that so you know what what
we'll test it my only issue is getting
this Channel striked and it affects IOP
you know what I'm saying uh so I want to
avoid that uh but we're just going to
put up pictures yeah pictures for now uh
you know we'll see we'll see uh you know
I might
I might play around and see what we can
get away with so so my question to you
right because everybody says you know
well not everybody I had a lot of people
complaining about the direction of the
movie and uh they didn't feel that it
was a cohesive thought they thought that
the movie was a hodgepodge some people
said you know awful things then you had
other people that were you know like
like me uh thought it was below black
panther one and and I don't think
anything can like actually fit in those
shoes but I still believe that it's
probably the if not the second best
phase four film and me with um
Spider-Man
um no way home as as probably number one
and this is the second best uh and
Shanghai home was definitely yeah
because of what they did you know so
what do you think as a phase four film
uh what do you rank this
uh hold up let me right now I'm starting
a QA so you guys can uh ask us a little
bit of questions at the end of this you
know I'm not going to do them all but we
might do a couple that makes sense to us
on what questions that we want to answer
trying to be a little bit more uh you
know open to answering questions from
the the community uh I think this is
this is the second I would put this to
the second uh I think I think
what's uh I I think no way home was by
far the best like not even like it's
literally a landslide how much better
this is than the other ones and then I
would probably go
I would go this black panther I don't
know like sure she was good like yeah
change uh I always butchers it was good
I'm just
I don't know like I would have to really
sit there and think but I do know one
thing this is better than Thor this is
better than
um the madness one with uh doctor
strange it's better than all of those
people yeah oh I I forgot about like was
that really a fourth face yeah yeah they
they dragged that thing out buddy
that thing was supposed to be like phase
three or phase two
oh man I hate that I hate that for them
like that yeah that that's unfortunate I
I would say this is this is neither
second or third because you know the the
Rings man that was good that was a good
movie I love that Rings movie especially
you know what I liked is just
I like when a villain is redeemed at the
last moment I don't know why but I like
that kind of storyline and when he was
sitting there in that movie and and he
knew he was dead like he knew he was
dead there's nothing he can do he's like
let me get these Rings up on here let me
get these Rings up on my son like
because I because I don't think he had
to do that did he no he didn't you know
but he passed them off because he knew
he was going to die yeah it was okay so
all right so we got you know uh Sherry
being the Black Panther
how did you like me more when he when
they captured Sherry and they take her
down the tolucan and he he puts in that
that that that's the giant walking space
suit the underground underwater
spacesuit I I liked her he was like well
if you go around where you your bones
are gonna break he's like you're pretty
much gonna die he's like or he could put
you in a suit we do got some of those
look it feels like he's schizophrenic
um but also he's hell-bent on killing
the scientists like feed a fresh fruit
uh give her water give her this you know
I I gotta kill her right yeah and you
know what's interesting I saw someone in
the chat earlier say yo
I just didn't
um you know Iron Man was more advanced
like his suit like that scientist I
don't uh I don't know remember her name
but look yeah well you got to look at
like
Tony built the Iron Man suit with wealth
yeah she doesn't have it like you know
I'm not going to say that that suit will
ever be as advanced as Iron Man suit but
don't
don't act like just because she built
that suit and it wasn't as strong as an
Iron Man suit doesn't mean that she
couldn't build technology close to that
quality like she built that in a matter
of a couple days it felt like like but
that doesn't make any sense right
because you got to think about it I mean
and not your statement but the state
statement from um the chat well they
said because because Tony's suit could
uh was like on like a watch but it's
like it was nano technology but yeah at
that how many movies did he gets
technology right so he he went through
many iterations of of said Tech Mass
Fortune this girl and she's remember
she's an 18 19 year old kid
that gets to go to wakanda and has only
been there for a day and a half
and she finishes a suit that she had in
Prototype that was over in ninja pretty
much like a giant warehouse and what's
funny I like you know who I really stuck
front in this
um the the guardian uh the uh the one
that got dethroned although you're
talking about
um um don't forget her name yeah you're
talking about uh a Corey you kind of saw
like
her whatever like the the old-fashioned
come out of her a little bit in this
movie like you saw her like I love when
they walked in that warehouse and she's
like so you you you have the blueprints
to this giant machine in this Warehouse
[Laughter]
on a hard drive yo she she didn't want
to have the AI Drive in the car she
didn't want to put on that night uh the
night uh Whatchamacallit Nightshade suit
she thought it was ugly she thought it
was cumbersome but it helped her in the
battle with a tuna a tumor
um Okoye it broke my heart
when the queen
demoted her
yeah I kind of I understood like
mentally what she was going through but
I do feel like she jumped the gun she
didn't even see because clearly if these
people like she's had Communications
with these people like
I I guess you she can't speak rationally
because she she's mourning already her
son and she's thinking her daughter's
gone too so I think maybe that's what it
was mainly but it's just like to me you
picked up the throne very well I felt
like you could have said my chances are
my daughter's not dead you know what I'm
saying like but I understand it like you
know they're going through like she she
she's right now grieving and she's
thinking that her daughter's dead and
she's just taking it on the person that
insured her that she would stay alive
but it's just like you know what name or
was capable of you sent your daughter
there willingly pretty much so it's just
like you did that just as much as she
did that but how many times does people
take accountability really especially if
you uh in a hierarchy type of type of
situation she lost her husband
she lost her son
now her daughter the only kid her whole
you know uh family lineage is probably
like wiped out but
and I say a big butt because the last
cut scene the last end credit
gave information that she knew
that that wasn't the last
but that doesn't mean that you're not
heartbroken at the same time but when
this one says you know I turned against
my husband
I gave up everything my whole life has
been dedicated to the Dora milaje I I've
my my I've set myself uh as a guardian
for this crown for for uh this this
whole situation
and Angela Bassett you know the queen
she she had to tell her
when killmonger took over
you rolled with him yeah I felt her on
that when she said that yeah I felt her
yeah
I think when she said that it realized
to her and I think that's the reason she
started slowly letting go that tradition
throughout the movie because she's like
what a tradition really get me in the in
the grand scheme of things nothing
nothing
what's funny is that she was such a
serious character like such a serious
character and she had she had comedy
relief in there and that's not normal
thing like that I love at the end when
she was like do I really Gotta Wear this
like dude I don't gotta wear this right
it just especially at the beginning when
they kind of like
foreshadowed her using that suit at the
beginning when she's like why did it
every time I see this it gets uglier
like and what I like is when she puts
out my question to you is she keep the
suit is she wearing that suit in another
movie yeah both okay so it's two suits
that's why she asked how many suits you
have excuse me it was two suits made for
the nightshades and I think it will be
four in total but um
night shades all right so that's like
the elite of the wakanda so yeah yeah
because that that suit is vibranium Tech
it's like pitcher Tony Stark's suit
vibranium doubt type of thing and you
know very manageable suits very durable
and battle very flexible very a thin
sheet that's why she was able to fight a
tumor uh in in the matter she was and
I'm glad she didn't kill a tumor because
um he's he's his General right you got
tiger shark that comes later
um
um Marina that comes later other
characters that will come with uh you
know submariner's name or
those characters will come but this the
level of strength that they're able to
exhibit under the water
and take it outside of the water because
they're under which gives me tons of
pressure they uh physiology I always
messed that word up uh their bodies are
stronger than you know normal humans so
they have they can lift more they can
probably lift uh every Atlantean well a
total can can live probably one ton
whereas you know humans you know what
some what a hundred two hundred pounds
tops type of thing so they're very
strong very agile very quick but their
weaknesses they need oxygen I mean water
to you know for oxygen so you just break
that respirator type of thing and you
can defeat them so it's it's it's it's
it's a good mix with the suits versus
the what the atlanteans well the tolkans
bring to the table and my question to
you
what did you think about when they went
on water to fight the Atlantis because I
thought it was the stupidest thing they
could possibly I felt like they I
understand what they were trying to draw
them out
but I do feel like you and because if
you look at the end they had a lot of
people on that ship but at the end they
had like seven like they lost a lot of
people they literally sent people to
their death doing that it is just like I
felt like you could have figured out a
different strategy like you know and
what's funny is like if you
I get it they wanted to separate the
king from all the rest but it's just
like
first off you didn't expect to just
throw a spear down and stab through the
floor like you didn't expect that like
it was just okay she was like how much
damage like tremendous I'm like oh so
you never expected him to use his only
weapon and not and step into the floor I
guess maybe they didn't they didn't
understand how much draining him of
water would like actually realistically
um you know de-power him and I think
maybe she thought it would happen sooner
than it did
no whoa you know what what it was was
they don't understand the properties of
raw vibranium versus the manufactured
vibranium oh so she thought this the
ship would hold up right that's why she
was like uh give me the Integrity of the
hole
that would make sense she did seem like
thoroughly surprised he did that yeah
like what the hell like it actually
broke through the floor in the manner
that he is and he's grinding it there
pause
um
I
being that name was probably 500 years
old uh by the time he gets to fight
Sherry
I was taken about that
they were on equal footing when it came
to oh well of course he was drained if
he would have been at his Peak I'm kind
of curious just to ask you a question
real quick does his little flying things
grow back or does she stop him from
flying ever again
and you could tell the look at him he
was like it's like it's like no nothing
ever that like ever happened before he's
like oh oh if I can't fly no more I've
never been put in this situation before
horrified absolutely horrified only one
character did that to himself oh a
couple of characters but one character
in particular of a book that I read was
um Venom did it
ripped uh ripped his little wings over
his feet and mocked him but he paid very
dearly for doing I could see Venom
eating them too after he rips them off
something terrible yeah absolutely
disgusted uh but you got to know name
more is as strong as the Hulk
in the water and that's a that's a not
in Rage talk like you know face level
Hawk right in the water and outside of
the water he's uh you say thoris
strength right and that's going through
the comic books because uh in in the
movies in MCU the books is flipped you
know Thor is the I'm uh omnipotent one
and you know the Hulk is uh lesser in
MCU as only because they don't have the
rights yeah but they own him in June so
expect that to change so when he turned
and he punched Ibaka in the chest and
they didn't kill broke
his his armor
he broke his that armor is low level
vibranium
so he punched him and it broke it
dear God that's why it was so amazing
when he did it and Ibaka looked at him
and Ibaka was able to say we got to do
this out there flying around as strong
as the Hulk
how did you feel about them giving him
the throne at the end of the movie
it was a natural succession he was the
only one with enough foresight to tell
Sherry that you don't want to burn down
the world he was the only one looking
for a peaceful solution to a situation
yeah from him considering like where he
came from
from yeah from the from the first film
where he wanted to kill t'challa and it
kind of made me feel like
because of the council that he gave her
her not contesting him was his reward
yeah because he knew he can't take on
the Black Panther
but that's not something that he wanted
anyway I mean like she didn't want the
mantle and he didn't want to fight her
but
he also knew what's best for the people
because the people wanted to go to war
with Neymar and he was the only one with
the voice of reason like
no like you're the only way to
understand what we're fighting is
because the Black Panther we showed up
if she would never have done what she
did they probably wouldn't have went to
war with them so at all and he would
have demolished them a week later
basically because he said I'll be back
yes he did he did Arnold I'll be back
and what's funny is like he didn't even
make sure no one was dead he drowned
them and was like I'm Gonna Leave You
guys here I'm gonna be back in a week I
guess he assumed the scientists would
have just died but he just flew off I I
thought he was gonna grab the scientist
and leave with her
you know the wildest thing
all the technology
for all the defenses that they have they
never expected them to come from beneath
and those dudes came from water and
scared the life out of them because they
were not prepared for that level of
infiltration From Below
and that showed them that they have a
complete weakness when it comes to that
and I want to know if it's going to be
addressed within the Thunderbolts
because you know Val is going to take
yeah look let's talk about the elephant
in the room Val locking her husband up
listening to the conversations of of
shuri and um or the queen and Ross and
you know I like I like how they made it
seem like she was trying to re-spark
that marriage the whole movie and then
at the end she was playing him the whole
time she had the handcuffs
[Music]
and people uh in my initial review of
the film excuse me
you got to look at the struggle of the
in the wakanda is not struggling but you
got to look at the the wakandan aspect
of it you got to look at the the Incas
aspect of it I love the fact that they
addressed
the what happened to the Mayans and they
they flipped Neymar's script into uh the
Mayans where the the Mayans left and
this is where they went right because
they couldn't use Atlantis because of
Aquaman and all that whole stuff that
red tape and all that movie jogging crap
they couldn't use that and they had to
find a different way but I love the fact
that they went with the Incas the Mayans
and it went with this this type of
lineage this type of story so we saw
their struggle here we saw the brown
struggle I saw the black struggle but we
saw
the white struggle as well because
she's talking bad his wife Val is
talking back to Ross and she's telling
him all these horrible things and he's
like they saved my life what are you
talking about
you you don't you don't know these
people and he's trying to stand up for
him you know it was scary when he was
like
I'm scared pretty much what will happen
if we had that vibranium he's like like
look you talk about what they have done
let's talk about what they haven't done
he's like they have all this technology
and all this resources and they've never
invaded anyone and he's like what
happens if America got that she's like I
dream of that I'm like oh God yeah like
every day
um and I'm like that's that's that's
terrifying in the sense that
he's fighting for for for that for for
Unity for safety for for coming together
and she is openly telling you
she's looking for remember she's when
they sat there they said so how are we
going to go about this destabilization
what we can we do who can we send in
there to destabilize their country
and I'm like wow typical tactics
that they that they destabilize
governments and they go in and she is
all on board with so you you know the
Thunderbolts is going to be uh Espionage
team that destabilizes countries because
you heard Winter Soldier told you
all those uh winter soldiers that they
had locked up remember that they went
and they went killing them
they each won one was capable of
destabilizing a whole country by himself
and they they they they mastered this
technique so again she has a whole team
of thunderbolts we're going to see
exactly what they do how to get into
wakanda how they destabilize wakanda
what's going to happen there because I
think that's the natural progression to
the story because they break uh Ross out
you know um
she comes in her Nightshade suit which
is kind of dope and she gets him out of
it I thought it was gonna be uh the
Black Panther that saved him for some
reason I knew it was going to be her
I for some reason I knew it was gonna be
I knew Sherry send them though but
that's that's a a guy
that has
treason put on his head so that gives
them the right to go and invade wakanda
to to retrieve
the prisoner
storyline
I I don't know she's so unpredictable
Val is so unpredictable but the way that
she was going around plucking certain
strategic characters from different
places
uh shows me that she's getting
characters as are in a gray area
so you know I don't think it could be uh
compromised morally so we do I I have
one more little segment uh shout out to
Paris Lockhart in the chat he said uh
hashtag recast to Charlie let's talk
about that uh the cut scene at the end
it showed that the Charlie actually
and I think that is their way of you
know honoring his memory but still
keeping at least the name around it's
not going to be tatala but it's going to
be a sun how do you think they're going
to do that because I got my own theories
how they're going to handle that how do
you think they're going to do with that
storyline film I'm jumping you think
it'll be something like the infinity War
the end game where there's like a Time
skip
well you saw we didn't see him as an
infant right yeah he was he yeah
probably early teen uh yeah so he get
him like he's like uh 10 or 11 years old
um so remember when we first got it it
was six year uh time Jump Right that uh
he she was going for six years so the
kid had to be six years old because she
wasn't pregnant when she left so she had
to leave while she was pregnant all
right so six years passed and then by
the time the end of the film goes this
kid comes out he looks like he's 9 10
11.
um we're gonna have a similar time Jump
when the next Black Panther comes out so
you say that he's going to be in his
pre-teens or early teens if not 15 16
years old you could say there you can
work for a young black panther because
they if you watching if you're watching
the script you see Scarlet Witch have
two kids
you see Thor is now a new daddy right
um they're setting their kids to take
the mantle right you see uh an Ant-Man
his daughter after the time skip she's
now in an eligible age to be uh a hero
you know she's older than she was when
he was gone for five years and when he
blipped back in
they're setting it up for the Young
Avengers right we're gonna get that so
the young black panther actually works
within that Young Avengers type of thing
it it works and they don't need to rush
him into that space but you keep the
t'challa name going so comic book heads
don't lose a black panther those people
that are wishing that Chadwick Boseman
doesn't get uh recast they have the herb
there so he's going to take the herb
there will be a new black panther did
you like how she reprinted more of them
like yeah but did you notice she didn't
put them in that cave she put them in in
the in the woods like the fort it was It
was kind of weird right
so I I don't know what type of uh
defenses they're gonna have for that
herb but uh hopefully it's you know it's
it's fortified but I I thought them
burning the herb at the last film was
really at a detriment and they kind of
rectified their retcon that they you
know with Neymar's help
um
it it
we're going to have a new black panther
it's gonna take some time I'd say by the
end of film three
he won't be assuming the mantle but
we'll be getting a young black panther
in the suit going through the young
stages of growing into a black panther
it lends to more movies
yeah um obviously everything's
money-wise they do anything to generate
Revenue in the future uh this is
something that DC has lacked is the
ability to forsight future endeavors
like later on in in the timeline uh so
you know I'm hoping you know we'll we'll
see some move on that I would assume
they're going to give share a few years
of being black panther and then they'll
naturally move it to his son when he
becomes of the age where they feel like
that's comfortable uh that last question
I got for you King is where you think
the uh Marvel's direction is what do you
think's going man
oh you you have all these TV shows
that's coming on uh Disney plus you know
the Iron Heart It was supposed to be the
um armor Wars but armor Wars got turned
into a movie you got uh Guardians of the
Galaxy coming up you have uh secret uh
Invasion then you have uh Secret Wars
you have uh the king Wars
it's all gonna build up to you you have
Ant-Man you have all these movies
building up to Kang as the big back Loki
two you know we have all these shows and
all these movies that going that are
going in that direction so Chang is the
obvious big big bad what's behind that
is it
um Galactus eating these these timelines
eating these planets in these timelines
what actually happens we have what if
um also coming we have uh what is it
Marvel Zombies actually coming so it's
it's different timelines that we're
going to get so I think the Multiverse
we have X-Men those those those
characters is coming all that stuff is
going to happen I just think it
accommodates with King
fighting off Avengers from different
timelines Avengers that didn't die or
Avengers that were maybe we do get Tom
Cruise as Iron Man from one Arc you know
uh maybe we do get uh Brad Pitt as Thor
in one Arc you know we don't know
um maybe we get Hyperion because I was
hoping that we get Henry Cavill showing
up as Hyperion in in one of these films
I don't know
but uh we can get these characters we
can get uh the void it's a lot of stuff
that they can do with this Multiverse
and the fact that they are no longer
holding the hands of the crowd because
if they can show you sombereness
in death and and rebirth and death in
the beginning of this film and at the
end
she was putting away her past and they
showed you rebirth in as as well as you
know death at the end then they they
show the uh the audience that they are
comfortable with bearing you know all
the emotions to them because this film
had a long range of emotions to me yeah
I think they did a really good job on
this this film this is the last film for
phase four right yeah I believe so yeah
what um
what is what is your ranking what do you
get of it uh yeah so I'm gonna give it
four popcorns I'm gonna give it a full
popcorn I'm gonna give it four popcorns
I want to see your popcorns yeah they're
they're up there I'ma give it
the question is what are you giving
I give it a full popcorn as well King is
also giving it a four-part code so we
have beautiful we have four popcorn so
we got a five dollar super trap from
ever born Saga I heard a theory that
instead Kang descending from Reed uh
Richard's bloodline he would uh come
from t'challa's bloodline
who King yeah
no
well I'm just telling you ever born said
I mean
King King operates outside of the the
time space continuum if we watched Loki
he's an entity that can't be tracked in
a time space continuum but he's constant
in every time space continuum so when
you remove him from one time space
continuum he just splinters into a bunch
and every time space continuum until
Kang is all
that that's what he was trying to
explain to Loki
I'm going to be all I'm going to be
infinite so if you kill me now you're
going to have to deal with me later or
you can team up with me now so you don't
have to deal with me later but you're
going to have to deal with me at some
point in time and Loki chose well you
know Loki chose to kill him
so now you have to deal with them that's
why when you see this King he has a
slash on his face inside Ant-Man because
that's not the same King but it is the
same King if you understand what I'm
saying he was pretty much in Loki saying
I'm grounded right now but if you kill
me I will become more powerful than you
can imagine like out of control and he
is that's why when you see the Army he
that he amassed in the trailer of
Ant-Man
he is Buck bananas
yeah and tank is really something and
the avenger movie is going to be all the
kings right
no they're going to be fighting each
other for Supremacy oh God I didn't know
that yeah I thought it was yes I thought
it was going to be like all the kings
together fighting the Avengers it can
only be one it's like Highlanders 12. we
got a question what do you think of
aligning young d'challa with the release
of mutants perhaps you can pair young
storm with young t'challa yes that would
be a good way bringing the uh of
combining the two IPS because I don't
know nothing about Comics but I do know
that they end up together some form away
or something like that yeah she she
becomes his wife
uh and it was it was a good feel-good
story you know for the books even those
two
is talking about the original one the
original uh King the one that they uh
that Loki killed I assume
he's done
yeah and did he come from t'challa's
bloodline I don't think so
uh ever going to July Super Chat the
first king was uh no I Daniel Rich oh
you're talking about in the books
the first king is not Nathaniel which is
the first king inside the books oh my
god well I'm a Tut remember
um Roma Tut isn't Nathaniel Richards
that's later on when you got the the
Reed Richards world
me and you'll talk about that like it's
it's a it's a whole timeline where it's
nothing but a bunch of Reed Richards and
they all from all over and they all go
into one it's like Rick's Rick and Morty
if anybody watches Rick and Morty it's
like the the Council of Ricks you have
the Council of Richards and
yeah it's it's it's a thing it's a thing
so it's pretty much the the end of our
first episode I I think it went well
technically technical wise nothing
happened thank God because because most
the time everything be going wrong when
you try to launch a new show uh like I
said but I am gonna have a like a
spoiler Cascade you know I'm thinking
King you know the original game pass
trailer where it showed game pass with
the neon signs yeah I might have a
spoiler alert made with those neon signs
that works and I'll have that playing in
the middle when we're talking spoilers
stuff don't worry you can catch uh attic
and I twos days 5 p.m so on your drive
time going home or if you're eating you
know yeah yeah yeah your dinner you know
you can catch us talking about what we
saw that week what movie came out that
week or yeah this would be nice this
would be everything TV and movie related
and we'll try to throw in a little bit
of anime on there I'm not gonna try to
drown you guys with too much anime we'll
probably just cover like the big big
stuff because I don't know some of you
don't care about that stuff I'm going to
watch Attack on Titan Attack on Titan so
we don't have a weekly weekly uh what
what happened Attack on Titan with King
okay I'm with that I'm with that I can't
see you know with Attack on Titan but um
listen we want you guys to to
participate so we're gonna put up at the
end of every show uh so starting next
week what should we watch what do y'all
suggest and we'll have a poll and
whatever pops up there we'll watch it
and we'll talk about it the following
week so please don't put up nothing like
Gossip Girl
um yeah so okay hold up hold up let's
clarify we have to approve okay if if
you try to have me watch some off the
wall rocker stuff I'm not doing it I'm
gonna be real with you I'm not doing it
it's got to be something that I'm
actually going because here's the thing
I gotta actually remotely have interest
in something to have like if it's
something I know I'm not gonna like
don't expect me to watch it like now
obviously if it's something that you
know I'll pop up a trailer I'll watch
okay let me try this like I'm willing
I'm willing to to to
to have a middle ground with you guys
the moment you guys make me watch some
off The Rocker stuff that I don't like
that is when I pull the rug from you
guys that is one that is no longer
happening all right so addict your
homework this week and and my homework
this week
is to watch the Barbarian on Netflix I
think it's on Netflix or is it on uh HBO
Max
um it's on either HBO Max or it's on
Netflix it's called The Barbarian they
come out and no the uh hold up let me
did it just come out
it's it yeah it came out like uh at
least three weeks ago I think yeah I see
Barbarian trailer yeah yeah it looks
like it's got uh Justin Long in it
something scary yeah I'll watch it I'll
watch it yeah so we'll be talking about
the Barbarian next week uh so hopefully
you guys like that and uh get your
questions and stuff ready thank you for
showing up peace yeah it was it was
definitely good uh you know it's like I
said we'll see you guys next Tuesday I'm
gonna watch the Barbarian and King will
watch a couple episodes of Attack on
Titan and we'll uh we'll we'll we'll
we'll tackle that first and then we'll
tackle like the big stuff that comes out
like I said it's gonna be about
everything but we'll tackle you know the
homework first and then we'll go in and
Branch out so